so from today onwards so we are going to
start
automation part so which is selenium
webdriver
so in the today's session we will see uh
introduction part like what is in a web
driver
and how we have to set up the web driver
in pi champ and uh we will see how to
write a simple a very basic test case in
selenium webdriver we will try to
automate the test case
so let us understand the basic
information like theoretical
understanding we need to have
so what is a selenium web driver
so basically cilium contains a multiple
components like selenium ide selenium
drive or selenium rc selenium grid there
are multiple components are there
and most popular one is a celina webb
driver so web driver is one of the
component in selenium webdriver is one
of the component in selenium and which
is a famous component
by which we can automate the web
applications especially we can automate
the web application because prelim
itself is supporting only web
applications especially web driver we
use to
uh
automate web applications
now
what is another what what is another
definition of web driver so web driver
we can simply say a package
web driver is simply a package
okay web driver is a simple a package
uh in python we can simply say but in
with respect to java we can call it as a
interface but here we can call it as a
package or we can
uh it is basically not a package which
is basically a model we can simply say
okay webdriver is a model we can simply
say
so this is another definition of web
driver with respect to python
so web driver uh is having as i say web
driver is a model right so model means
what module contains the functions
module contains the classes and again
classes contains a different type of
methods right
so this module contains a various number
of classes
like each browser there is a different
class is available so for example
if you want to automate the
test case on firefox browser so then we
have a firefox class
okay suppose if you want to automate
your test case on chrome browser then we
have to use a chrome class
and then if you want to automate or if
you want to run your test case on edge
browser we have a hd class similarly
there are so many browser support is
there so all kinds of browsers
they're having a dedicated classes are
available so all these classes are
available inside the web driver model
webdriver module
so we have to import this module then we
will get all these classes and we will
able to access all the method from the
classes and then we will able to
automate your test case
so this is the fundamental understanding
which we need to have
and apart from all these things there is
one more definition we have
web driver is an api
web driver is an api which is
application programming interface
so before discussing uh what is why web
driver is naked what is an api we need
to understand what is the application
programming interface
so if you know what is an api then we
will understand why web driver is an api
okay
so basically the api means application
programming interface
and when you talk about the web
applications let me just open the paint
so when i take any kind of web
application there are multiple layers we
have
so let us say one layer is
called as a
we can let's say this is the database
and there is another layer
here and there is another layer here
there let us say three-day architecture
if i take any web application mainly
three
level architectures will be there
and the first level we can call it as a
gui or we can say user interface
and which is also called as a
presentation layer which is also called
as a presentation layer
now the last layer is basically called
as a backend area which is basically
database and which is called as a
backend
layer
back in layer
and what is this middle layer is called
as a application
or
web
server
and which is also contains a business
logic which contains a business logic
which contains a business logic
now if i just look at this this is the
whole architecture of
web application if you take any web
application so this is the basic
architecture we will have
so if i just look at this architecture
so what is presentation there means
always the user will interact here okay
so the user will always interact with
this application always the user will
interact with this application so which
our application were able to access
which is called as a presentation layer
through browser we are able to access
the application by sending the url
suppose i want to open google.com so
what i will do you can just simply you
send this url and you will get some data
here you will get some information here
right so from where we are getting this
data where from where we are getting
this search box and all these elements
somewhere from the server we are getting
this data as soon as you send some
request we got some response here
but we will receive this response we
will receive this request and we will
process the request and we will send
this response so all these things will
be taken care by
a component called
business logic so this business logic
will take care of everything
and this business logic in the sense
which contains n number of programs and
based upon the request you send
accordingly particular logic will be
executed and this will send the same
request to the database layer and fetch
the data and again send back the
response and the same response will be
presented in user understandable format
so that is the actual process will
happen
so when you send a request
when you send a request
and we will get the response we will get
the response
so here this business logic in the sense
which contains n number of programs
there are so many programs will be there
and which is basically developed by
programming languages by the developers
right
but again
this business logic is divided into
multiple classes
which are called them as a apis
application programming interface so
this is business logic in the sense the
programs
so all the programs collectively we can
call it as apis application programming
interfaces so not only one api there are
so many apis will be there in this
business logic there are so many apis
will be there
and depends upon the type of request
corresponding api will be triggered and
this api will process the data in the
database and get the response and the
same response will be again presented to
the presentation layer so who is doing
all these things is apis doing all these
things
so why we can call this is the api
application programming interface means
what application in the sense this is a
one through presentation layer whatever
the url we are sending accessing that is
application
and the programming is what programming
is talking about the business logic this
is the programming layer
and what is an interface interface means
what this business logic or api is
acting as an interface between our
presentation layer and the backend layer
or which is called as a database layer
so that's the reason we can call it as a
api application programming interface
okay so this api will be automatically
triggered and corresponding request will
be again sent back to the send to
database and get the response and same
response will be presented to the
presentation here so here api is acting
as a
mediators between presentation layer and
a backend layer
so every application internally having
so many apis
so when you conduct testing right so in
this particular area when you conduct
testing in this area we can call it as a
gui testing
gui testing so normally we do using
selenium so we always test the browser
so here browser will be there so we will
do browser level testing
and when you conduct the testing
directly on these apis we can call it as
a api testing
so here api testing come into picture
so now evidence it is becomes a more
popular api testing
these aps we are directly testing by
send by passing some input to the api
getting some response and directly we
are verifying the response directly we
are validating the response
and that is called api testing and here
we use like postman rest i showed karate
so there are so many types of tools are
available in the market which will by
which we can perform the api testing
and other level is backend layer is also
there so in the backend layer also we
can conduct some kind of testing which
we can call it as a database testing
database testing or we can say back-end
testing
so if you give any application if you
want to do end-to-end testing of
application we have to conduct gui
testing api testing and database testing
and again performance testing or
security testing will be there in every
level so in the geo testing also
performance testing is required in the
api level also performance testing is
required in the database level also
performance testing is liquid so those
are comes under again non-functional
type of testings
okay so here when you talk about the
functional level of testing so these are
the main three different layers we will
conduct three different type of testings
so and again each layer is completely
different and tools also will be
different so we by using single tool we
cannot do everything but there are
certain tools are available which will
support all kinds of testing but
especially selenium is only for gui
testing and postman rest issued these
things so we can use for api testing and
toad or some other clients we can use
for database testing so these are
completely back interesting
so here
the main importance of apis which will
process the request and the database
layer first it will get the request from
the user and send the same request to
the database layer and process the data
and whatever response we get it here the
same response will be provided to the
presentation layer that is a response we
are able to see on the ui so this is
actual thing the ap will do that
so based on this understanding let us
see why webdriver is an api
so this we need to understand why
webdriver is an api
so to understand this why webdriver is
an api we need to
uh
understand the architecture of selenium
webdriver how exactly webdriver works
internally
and accordingly we will able to
understand why webdriver is a
api okay so let me just take one more
picture
let me save this as picture one
okay let me just open one more so now
i'll tell you why webdriver is an api
so
here how webdriver works so so let us
say this is my browser
and let's say this is my application
under test
so this is aut we can call it as a aud
means what application under test
application under test
aud means application under test so this
is application which we are going to
test so normally where we can see the
application on the browser level
right so browser means what it can be
chrome
or it can be firefox it can be edge
whatever it is so this is basically
browser
right which is basically browser so all
the applications will run on the browser
because this is a gui level of testing
so to run this test cases let us say we
have written some automation code okay
so let us say
i have written some automation code here
so let us say this is my automation code
i have written
so different statements i have written
in java or python whichever language you
used
so basically this particular this is our
automation code
okay this is our automation code
this is our automation code
so once you write your automation code
when you execute your automation code
what will happen
whatever actions we have written inside
this code the same actions will be
performed on the application
suppose there is a login box i want to
enter username in the textbox login
username textbox and then i want to
enter password in the password box so we
will perform those actions whenever you
run your automation code or automation
script it just seems very similar to the
python program
so when you execute this actions will be
performed on the browser level on the
browser but however automation code will
talk to the browser so our automation
code cannot directly talk to the browser
so internally we need another layer here
so what is that layer as web driver
so here webdriver come into picture
so webdriver
we can call it as an api here so
webdriver
is a api so what is webdriver contains
again so many classes so many methods
are there so we are all referring those
classes and methods inside our program
so our automation code will not directly
talk to the browser so our automation
code first
talk to the web driver interface so
which is basically contains so many
classes and method
and those methods
will directly execute the statements on
the application under test
okay so again webdriver also cannot
directly talk to the browser but again
the browser drivers are required here so
without drivers even webdriver apis also
cannot directly talk to the application
so i will show you that architecture
later so first let us try to understand
very high level architecture of
webdriver so if i just look at this here
i have automation code and here i have a
web driver as an interface and here
application under test so what is the
job of web driver here what webdriver is
doing
so whatever the statements have written
in my automation code
webdriver is taking those statements or
understanding those statements
and accordingly the web driver will
executing those statements under
application under test
so how this web driver is working here
it is acting as an api
between our automation code and the
browser
so that is the reason we can call this
as a api web driver is also contains so
many classes and methods
so when i say normal apis also contains
so many classes and methods similarly
web driver module also contains so many
classes and so many methods
so by using those classes or by calling
those methods
we will able to interact with the
browser and these statements whatever
actions we perform the actions will be
performed or to be done on the
application
so that is the reason we can call
webdriver is an api so that is a
statement we need to understand
so here
web driver
web driver is an
api is an api
okay so now based on this understanding
let us see the in detail architecture
how exactly webdriver internally works
internally talk to the browser
so let me just share a small
presentation so architecture level
in three dot x cylinder m3 and cylinder
four there are uh some changes are there
okay so in the selenium four is not
officially released in the market
but they have done uh some changes okay
they have released the beta version so
so far the beta versions are coming out
but they are not officially certified
still enough for till now
so psyllium three dot x three there are
so many versions are there again so they
are certified versions and stable
versions
okay cilium 4 is still not released but
only beta versions are released so in
them so they have done some changes in
beta version they have done some
architectural changes especially and
they have also implemented some new
features cm4 so i will show you those
features also
because uh we are going to see serium
four part okay
so selim three dot x if i just look at
here if anybody asked an interview what
is an architecture of psyllium so we
have to tell two different type of
architectures
because in clm3 there is one type of
architecture in slim 4 there is another
type of architecture
now if i just see ethereum 3.x
architecture how exactly selenium
webdriver works
so here we have something called
selenium client library
so what is a meant by client library
here so client library in the sense
uh web driver is providing certain
number of jar files class files all
these things right so we can call them
as a library which are called as a
client library so if i just look at the
picture again so the program whatever we
are writing right in the program we are
going to call different classes and we
are going to use different classes we
are going to call different type of
methods which are belongs to webdriver
so all these things comes under
selenium like client library
so now psyllium support python cilium
support java serum support shisha ruby
so these are the different languages are
supported by selenium
so psyllium classes and methods are
available
in multiple languages
okay so multiple languages so that's the
reason if you want to write your
automation script in java
and you can write or python sheesh or
ruby so these are all languages
supported so
psyllium webdriver classes and methods
are already implemented
in multiple languages we can call them
as a selenium client library so we can
use one of the library to automate your
test cases whichever language you are
familiar with you can go and use that
particular library okay
now let us understand here how this
library so let us say this library is
nothing but a simple program
let me take a python so i have written
some automation code in python so we can
come we can call this a client library
for example
so when i write a code in my python how
this will basically interact with the
browser as i said here
i directly shown here our automation
code will internally call the webdriver
methods and those methods will directly
interact with the browser but again this
is not direct communication there are so
many protocols are there so many drivers
are there internally we'll use but we
cannot see physically what exactly
happening but at the high level we need
to understand how they are going to work
okay so in between again there are
protocols are there and in between there
are drivers also there and then only
these components will talk to each other
and communicate each other
so now here between this client library
and a browser so here i have a browser
so let's say multiple browsers are there
like
chrome firefox internet explorer
edge or opera so you can have any number
of browsers
so our client library our program cannot
directly talk to the browser
so first of all we need something called
browser specific drivers
so for each browser there is a driver
and the driver is available in the form
of executable file
so if we want to work with the chrome
browser we need to have the driver and
if you want to work with the edge
browser we need to download the driver
or if you want to work with the firefox
pro then we need to download another
driver
so for every browser there is some
driver available so the driver we have
to download first of all
so these are all browser specific
drivers and we need to have those
drivers in your local machine first of
all okay without those drivers we cannot
directly communicate with the browsers
so we will develop these drivers we will
implement these drivers
selenium is not implemented these
drivers these drivers are implemented
by those companies suppose uh edg is
there edges from microsoft so they have
implemented edge driver
let's say chrome chrome is from google
so google is implemented the group
driver similarly each browser specific
driver is implemented their own
respective companies and those drivers
already available so we need to get
those drivers first
so whatever the automation code we have
written
and that code will directly talk to the
drivers first it will invoke the driver
through json protocol javascript object
notation this is a kind of a protocol
so don't worry if you're not understand
no need to go in depth of this
just try to understand this is simply a
kind of a protocol if some two
components need to talk for example
there are two persons are there if they
want to communicate each other there
should be some common language
right suppose one person knows hindi or
some other person knows english
suppose some other person knows telugu
right if these people want to talk each
other so there should be some common
language and that language everybody
should know similarly whatever here we
written the code in the python language
or the client or some other guy will
write the code in the java or some other
guy right in the c sharp or ruby in
whichever language we have written the
automation code
a json protocol like a common language
and which will able to process our
commands
and
call the browser specific drivers so the
communication
between our client library and browser
specific drivers will happen through
json wire protocol
json wire protocol this is a kind of a
protocol they have implemented so let us
assume this is simply a language kind of
thing these two components will talk to
each other
okay
now how browser specific drivers will
talk to the browsers
so here they use one more type of
protocol called as a w3c protocol so w3
is in the sense a world wide
conservative
means which contains at a number of
standards so every web application
should follow those standards which is
also called as one kind of a protocol
so throughout the world whatever
browsers are there whatever web
applications are there so they have to
follow
w3c consultant standards that is already
following every website if you design
some website or if you design some or if
you implemented some new browser so they
have to follow certain guidelines
or rules and regulations we can say
so that is w3c so w3c consulta which is
a basically correction of different
standards and by using those standards
they will communicate each other
so here the problem is
our drivers and browsers will
communicate each other by using w30 so
this a
communication will happen let's say
these two are talking in one language
but this guy is talking to this company
some other language
okay so that is how they have
implemented in cilium 3.x architecture
so here they are using one protocol
between these two components but here in
between these two components they are
using another type of protocol
so because of that they found some kind
of issues
unstability issues
so whenever you run your test cases
sometimes
without any reason sometimes it will
fail if you run bulk number of test
cases sometimes it will fail so people
will feel some unstability issues and
people will feel some performance
related issues
right so because of those reasons
so they want to change this protocol
in selenium four dot x
because these two
anyway talking with the w3c by using wcd
protocol
so if they make this protocol also w3c
then every kind of protocol is a
compatible
right so instead of talking to persons
in different languages if they know one
single language right so it is better to
talk in same language which is known by
both the people right same thing will be
happen here so these two components are
talking in w3c uh standard and this guy
is communicating through json protocol
so both are different so because of that
reason they found some kind of issues
with this json protocol
and then cm4.x they thought
instead of json provide protocol they
want to replace this with the w3
protocol itself
now in celium.4 what happens
this guy also communicating with the
client library using w3c product so now
everything is a w3c so everyone is know
the same language now so these drivers
understand w3c protocol browser can
communicate using w3c and now the client
library is also communicating through
w3s so because of this they have solved
some unstability issues and
communication also will become very
faster
so this is a architectural change they
have done in psyllium three dot x and cm
four dot x
okay other than that there is no
difference between three dot x and four
dots internally difference w three c and
silent four dot x they have implemented
some more new features so we will
discuss what are those special features
they have implemented in selenium four
dot x later
okay so this is a basic understanding of
selenium architecture especially in a
web driver architecture
so here are mainly three components one
is client library
and then browser specific drivers and
browsers anyway we have all the browsers
in our machine so at least you need to
have chrome browser ng browser firefox
browser and if you don't have these
three browsers just try to download and
install them because we will test all
automation code or we will run all the
automation test scripts in three
browsers basically because these are
three
uh browsers which are very popular in
the market so firefox edge and chrome
and these three browser from three
different vendors
but other than these browsers also
psyllium support other browsers and if i
just go to the selenium official website
psyllium dot dev so this is official
website selenium
and if i just go to the downloads
and you can just look at here what this
will support what this will not support
and these are the languages basically
which will support c sharp ruby these
are the client libraries we can say
these are the client libraries you can
see clearly salem clients and web driver
language binding so whichever language
we are going to use
for selenium so we have to use that
library now if i just come down to this
page again
they have clearly mentioned what are the
different browsers they will support and
just look at here so firefox is support
is there internet explorer is almost
duplicated actually because selenium
android explorer which is available till
version number 11 after that
microsoft is also not giving any new
features on this it is deprecated almost
new versions are not game because they
have introduced edge browser
okay so that is the one and safari opera
chrome
and edge so these are the
multiple browser support which is
available and similarly operating
systems which will support windows mac
and linux so these three operating
systems which will support
okay
so now based on this understanding what
we need to have we will download and
configure selenium client library the
first thing we need to have a browser
specific drivers and they also we need
to download and then we need to install
three different browsers at least
minimum three browsers we need to have
for practice purpose
okay but majority of the times we use
chrome browser but in the future essence
uh in initial sessions i will try to
work with three browsers and slowly
later on will completely uh depends on
chrome browser
okay because the same test case will
execute on multiple browsers so you no
need to change the test case
to run the test case on multiple
browsers but slightly we need to do some
kind of configuration settings and we
can do that
so this is very high level understanding
of selenium webdriver architecture
now let me just put it here what we have
learned so far
psyllium 3 first we need to have
language bindings
it will use json wire protocol to talk
to the browser specific drivers and this
browser specific drivers use w3c
protocol to talk to the browsers
and but selenium 4
selene language bindings
use instead of json wire protocol they
use w3c protocol and again browser
drivers still there and this is same so
this is not got change only this thing
is got changed because earlier this
protocol is developed by selenium guys
only psyllium people have developed this
so now this is replaced with the w3c in
cylinder 4.
so these are all architectural
differences between celiac 3 and
selenium four
okay
so as i said
uh before cilium three is a stable
version
and the cm4 is still not stable
we may face some kind of issues once you
start working with that but still fine a
majority of the things are working fine
but better to start learn with the
selenium four because this is going to
release as soon as possible
uh we'll see that okay
so this is a basic theoretical
understanding of what is selenium
webdriver how internally works
okay now
let us see how to set up and configure
webdriver in pie chart
that is the next thing
so to start working with automation we
need to
set up and configure web driver in
python so here we don't need to download
anything right you don't need to
download any software and we don't need
to install anything so just the
prerequisite is we need to install
python and pie chart so these two things
already there
so additionally we don't need to
download anything so we can easily
set up and configure webdriver in
pycharm directly
okay so now we'll see step by step how
we can set up and configure webdriver in
pycharm so before going further
so for that what we have to do is let me
just close it
so this is a selenium official website
and if you just go to the downloads
so they provided different language
bindings so which language we are going
to use python so in the python stable
version is this one almost 2018 they
have released this table version
till that time so from the last three to
four years they have not released any
new version only beta versions are
available
okay and uh this is also released on
june 7 2021 this version is released
recently in the last month okay
and uh
whichever version you want to use you
can still use it no problem so let me
just click on this beta
okay now it is going to another website
this is actual uh website
and they have provided all the
information how to install and
everything
so what we need to do is to install
selenium or to install selenium
webdriver
just we need to run this cam there are
multiple ways we can configure cylinder
webdriver there are multiple ways are
there so i'll tell you what are those
ways
so
this is official website actually okay
so before that what we need to do is
first step
step one is
prerequisites right so we need to have
some prerequisites what are the
prerequisites
that i'll show you
so the prerequisites are we need to have
a python should be installed on your
machine
the second thing is we need to have one
editor called pie chart
so we are using uh these two anyway so
far
so the next and most important thing is
so before installing the selenium
webdriver first we need to have the
browser specific drivers
because we are working with the we are
going to work with the three different
browsers so we need to
download those three drivers and keep
them in some place in your mission so
later on we will use the drivers so
let me so i said here right browser
drivers so if you want to talk to the
browsers we need those drivers our
automation script will use these drivers
and those drivers are available in the
executable format dot exe format
so we need to download them
so go back to the same website and they
provided all these things so now where
the browser specific drivers are
available we just come down to the same
page
and go to the browsers and here they
have given all the links actually for
firefox inter explorer so just go to the
documentation individually we can find
the drivers in those pages we can
download from there
so the other way is we can directly go
to this version
python and here
they already given some links i guess
somewhere let me i have seen some time
back just a moment
yeah now you can see here
chrome edge firefox safari so they have
directly given these links in this
python page itself
so we can use this link to do download
browser specific drivers
okay these drivers are mandatory
required which should be there in your
local machine
so let us first do this and then we will
see how to configure selenium webdriver
in pie chart so these are the links very
important i will just copy these links
here
so download
browser
specific drivers
drivers using below links
okay suppose you need a chrome driver so
open this
and go and open this link and they will
provide
multiple links again here so chrome
driver if i just come down there are
multiple versions are there
and again you have to choose the proper
version and first of all let's check
what is the version of your chrome
so go here and go to help and about
center help
about google chrome
and here you can see the which version
of google chrome you have so accordingly
you have to download the driver so
currently i have 92.0 is there and still
it is trying to update so let it
complete the updation
so 92.0 dot something is there and if i
just go back
so 93 driver is available but i don't
think browser is available so driver
will develop first and browser comes
later
so they will develop the drivers first
and then browser comes later
so exactly whichever version you have so
currently only 92 version is available
so we need to download 90 to chrome
driver so 92 dot in the 92 whichever the
latest version you have you can download
sometimes in the 920 itself we can see
multiple downloads but in whichever is
the latest version in 92 dot version you
can download
okay depends on the browser specific
version so once you click on it
here
and again show you multiple links and
depends upon your operating system we
have to download specific file so if i
just look at here windows mac
linux so there are multiple things are
there so currently we are working on
windows we have to click on this zip
file
so once you get this j file right so if
you extract the zip file
extract the g file into a folder
so now you will see one executable file
here chromedriver.exe
so this is a actual driver for
chromedriver chrome browser
similarly we should also download other
drivers again go back
and here
go back to the same page now this time
i'm trying to download edge driver
open this link
and this is hp so this is the latest
version of edge
again you have to check edge version so
whatever energy you have in your machine
you have to check the edge version
accordingly you have to check it so you
can just go to
uh
about help somewhere you can see here
help and feedback and about microsoft
edge
so here you can see this is also 92
version so because chrome agent chrome
chrome and microsoft edge will use
internally same kind of driver so it is
also 92 version is available
so we need to download 92 version so
this is the latest version
and based upon your operating system
again mac is different
arm means which is for linux operating
system mac is for mac open system on
windows there are two links are there so
almost windows is 64-bit operating
system you have to click on this
and which will also downloaded one more
zip file
now extract this into a folder
so then inside this you can see one more
executable file ms edge driver dot exe
this is another driver you have
and similarly let us try to download
for
firefox also so let's go and open this
link
okay
so this is the latest version i have so
0.21.29.1 so you can just download this
directly
or you can just come down these are the
actual links
so again depends upon your operating
system you have to choose right one i
have to use if you are working on mac so
you have to download this one or this
one
so currently we are working on windows
64-bit so i'm just clicking on this zip
file
and then it is downloaded
now go again unzip the folder
so once you unzipped you will get
one more executable file
so
decodedriver.exe the firefox driver we
can call it as a
geekodriver.exe
now totally three drivers we have
downloaded
so for firefox chrome and edge
so let us keep these three drivers in
one place so that we will refer these
drivers later in our automation script
okay so what i will do is the best
practice is just go to the c drive and
create one folder called drivers because
in future we are also going to download
different type of drivers if required
so go to the drivers and keep all the
drivers so whatever you have downloaded
these folders right so you can just keep
these three folder copy from here
and put them in the drivers folder so we
can keep anywhere else no problem at all
because
it is better to have one fixed folder in
which we will maintain all the
downloaded files which are required for
our automation okay so i'll keep all the
drivers here this is the best practice
and if i just look at here i have a
chrome driver here
and then i have a hg driver here
and then i have
gecko driver so this is for firefox so
all the drivers are kept in one place
and you can keep anywhere e drive c
drive wherever you want but maintain the
same location throughout your practice
okay so this is the first thing you have
to do right so step one we have to
download browser specific drivers
using below links
and uh once you download it we need to
extract those zip files you will by
default you will get a zip files
actually
so actual driver is in executable format
but at the time of downloading you will
get only zip files you have to extract
them again
okay so once you download it extract
those folders
so
i'm writing steps here once you download
it
then extract
[Music]
dot zip files
then
you will see dot exe files
what they are they are all drivers
they are actual drivers and keep them in
the drivers folder okay this is the
first step you need to have
so we have all browser specific drivers
and also we have a browsers three
browsers we have to install and keep it
ready with your machine one is firefox
one is chrome browser the other one is
edge browser
so everything is done so now the finally
we should get the selenium language
bindings
so if i just want to get the selenium
language bindings how we will get
just click on the beta version i'm just
going to you can go with the stable
version or going to beta version
anything is fine so i'm just going to
beta version
and or we can just start with the three
and later on we can install four also
okay we can switch to three to four also
multiple times so let us start with the
four because this is the latest version
and uh as soon as i started explaining
explanation i will also show you the
differences what is there in the three
what are the changes are then cylinder
four
so we'll also discuss those changes
at the time of explanation i'll give you
those changes so now this is the actual
official website from where we get the
instructions how to
set up the selenium webdriver
okay
so again
here to set up the selenium webdriver or
to set up a config webdriver so we have
it two options are there
so two options are there
setup webdriver we need to get the
webdriver module that's the main
intention here okay selena webdriver
model
setup selenium webdriver model
so to do this we have a two approaches
are there one is
within the pi charm we can do that
okay within the pie chart we can do that
and the second approach is by executing
the command
so they have given one simple command
here if i just execute this command
through your command prompt that will
automatically install your python what
is the command pip install selenium
actually this is not required just say
pp install cm which will install
selenium but by default 3.x is the
latest version
so which will install actually
pip.install version will be installed
by default but if you want to get 4 4 is
not at released so far but if you want
to install four forcefully then we have
to specify the version number
even if you specify three dot x here
three will be installed even though if
you're not specified this version number
by default this command will install
three
okay so this is either pycharm we can
use pycharm in the project settings we
have to install
it should go to project settings from
there we can install the python a web
driver silicon there's one option we
have second option is through command
prompt we have to execute this command
so either way we can go with that
now so i'll show you both the ways so if
you want to install selenium webdriver
set up in the pi charm how to do that
first we can create a new python project
so here the same project whatever we
created earlier we can still use the
same project
or
we can create another new project
but again if you create a new project we
cannot see this project in the same
window
okay so that is up to you if you want to
create a new project you can still do
that
or if you want to continue with the same
project we can still configure the same
project with silicon webdrive
okay so that is up to you so what i'm
going to do is this is my project right
so in the same project
i'll try to set up selenium webdriver
okay so then we can change the project
name later so or else we can create a
new project that is up to you how we
will continue i will just create a new
project for selenium especially we can
continue or you can continue with the
same project so that is up to you how we
can do that
so i hope you know how to create a
selenium pro how to create a python
project right so simply go to the file
new project
and here we have to specify the project
name so whichever project you want to
use you can just specify the project
name
and uh select this
python version whichever python you want
to use and then click on create which
will automatically create a new project
and then that in that project we can use
selenium webdriver or if you want to
continue with the same project you can
still continue that
so now how to install cylinder webdriver
or selenium webdriver module in the pie
charm so for that what you have to do is
we need to go to the file
go to the file
and
go to settings settings
and here you can see something called
projector right so whichever project
currently we are working so that project
will show here
and inside this you can see something
called python interpreter
python interpreter
so once you have this interpreter you
can just go and click on these are all
the different packages which are already
installed on pi champ
now we need to get a selenium so for
that we just click on this plus button
install button
and then here we have to search for
selenium so just search for selenium
now you can see there is a selenium
option is there
select only celium should be there okay
and then this is you can see here python
bindings for celium so by default which
version is installing
3.141.0 is a default version which is
installing so once you select here
click on install package so then it will
start installing selenium
in pie chart now you can see package
selenium installed successfully so once
you have done this you can just close
this window
now in this list in the python
interpreter in this list you can see
psyllium somewhere
here you can see the psyllium now which
version is installed by default 3.141.
installed
and suppose tomorrow if the 4.0 is
released officially then by default 4.0
will be installed
so this is a one way to install
python okay but if you want to install
four dot x like this it is not possible
because by default the pi jump is taking
the stable version
it is not taking the four dot x
but still if you want to install four
dot x only through
this command we can install
okay and with this command we can also
install three dot x only thing is we
have to just run only this command
without specifying the version
if i don't specify the version if you
run this command which will
automatically install cdm3 dot x default
but explicitly i want to specify
forcefully the version number so we have
to say you version number
okay now let me just uninstall from here
if you want to remove this package from
here you can again click on selenium and
click on the minus if i just a minus
which will automatically uninstall it
so package selenium successfully
uninstalled so this is the one way to
install selenium webdriver in pi chart
now the second way is here you can see
there are there is a terminal window so
this is basically called terminal you
can see multiple tabs in pycharm so when
you click on the terminal so you will
get this terminal so currently we are
working here
so this is a command prompt
this is a command prompt here we have to
execute this command so whatever the
command they have given pip install
psyllium equal to 4.0.0.d4
and uh
this is the installation process they
have given separately
okay so they given some example okay so
let's copy this as it is
and then
execute from the command prompter
i say paste
then execute
so that's it so which will automatically
execute selenium 4. okay so it is just
like pip version is older version which
is actual python which comes from the my
old python so you can just ignore you
will not get this warning okay
because pip is some small component
which will comes along with the python
okay so if my python version is little
older so even pp is also older version
so but still fine this single warning we
can ignore it
now finally successfully installed
selenium 4.0 version
and once you install here
again if you go and see the settings in
the interpreter you can see selenium
entry here
you can see selenium 4.0.0 d4 is
installed so even though it's the latest
version is showing like this but
actually what we have installed is 4.0
we have installed okay so these are the
two different ways we can install
selenium webdriver in pie chart either
through command prompt or through file
and settings
okay
so let me just show you
this is the first one
so this is the first approach we have to
give this command
so pip install selenium
and if you want to install this version
you have to use this whole command and
if you want to install only three dot x
just execute this command this is
approach one
anything is fine so whichever you
familiar you can just use it because i
just want to show you multiple
approaches okay this is approach one
the second approach is through
pycharm project settings
through python project settings you can
install so how to do that go to the file
and settings
project select the project project
interpreter and here click on the plus
button
search for selenium
and because which is already installed
that's the reason it is clearly giving
in the blue color so blue color means it
is already there
so we don't need to install again
fine so this is how we need to
set up series web driver so either go
with this approach one
or we can go with this approach too
anything is fine
okay
so we are ready with the browser
specific drivers
and we have ready with the cylinder
webdriver which is also configured in
our pyjam project
so now
we are ready to write our automation
code
this is the only setup you have to do
can you guys uh do that
by seeing these statements by following
these instructions please confirm in the
chat window
okay so very simple steps so step one we
have to download all the drivers keep
everything ready so safari is not
required if you are working on mac
safari is required rs not required
and once you download it extract the zip
files and then
you will see
dot executable files and keep them in
drivers folder in the second step we
have to install serial webdriver in
pycharm
by using project settings or
through terminal you can just execute
this command which will which will
install selenium
okay so once you have done so now let us
start writing a automation code
so we can continue with the same project
now here or else we can create another
project that is also fine
okay so let me just clear the console
okay so
i remove the terminal i can minimize the
terminal you can just click on the
terminal which will open and which will
minimize
okay
so now the same project i'm again
continue so let me just create new
directory for today
say day 11 right so this is underscore
selenium
i'm starting from day 11 so i'm just say
day 11 underscore silicon so this is a
new folder
so what is the test case which we are
going to automate my first test case
so listen this carefully if you
understand this test case it is very
simple and you can easily automate other
test cases
so let me just take one test case and
we'll show you how to automate this
okay so i have a small test case here so
we need to open a browser so whichever
browser first let us start with the
chrome browser and then later on i will
show you firefox and ie
then open this url
and provide this username and password
then click on the login button and then
capture the title of the dashboard page
which is actual title
and then verify the title of the page
this is the expected title what we are
getting through automation
and we need to compare these two tails
are equal or not if both are equal my
test is passed if both are not equal my
test is failure
so i you can do this as an assignment i
will take another application okay so
this is the one same test case so let me
open this application
so this is our hrm application so in
this
you can see username and password
okay use the limit password so username
is admin
i'll pass password is admin 123
and click on the login button
so once you have done this you will
enter into the dashboard page so here
you need to get the title of this
dashboard page
and then compare the actual title with
your expected title after successful
login what is the title should be there
in your page compare both the titles
both are equal my login test is passed
both are not equal my login test is free
so that is our test case
so open username password click on login
capture the title
and which is actual title we have to
capture through automation and then
verify the title of the page with this
this is our expected title both are
equal i'll make my test pass or fail
finally i close my browser so this is
simple test case i have taken so now
we'll see how we can write our
automation code
for this test case
okay now listen carefully
go to the pycharm
now i'm creating a simple a python file
okay
now here i'll name it as
uh my first test case
my first test case
and dot py so just like a module just
like a python file you have to create
first test case dot p1
so now i created one file
so let me just copy the steps whatever
you want to automate
go back and specify here so i'll just
put the comments okay
because
these are the steps we want to automate
this is our test case
okay
so this is our test case which we are
going to automate
now we will see step by step how we can
do that
so whenever uh
you want to
use or you want to
automate these steps the first and most
important step is we need to import web
driver module
so where is the map driver module is
available as i said before web driver is
a module actually web driver is a module
and a module in the sense which is
available in selenium package which is
available in the selenium package so you
need to carefully understand this
so webdriver
is
a module
is a module python module
which is available
which is available in selenium package
so selenium package we already installed
so obviously we get the webdriver model
so in the webdriver module only we have
all the classes and methods
so by using those classes and methods we
should able to automate
so now what we need to do as a first
step
if we want to access those classes and
methods from webdriver module
we have to import this webdriver module
from selenium package so which is
already installed right now go back
write the statement first statement
from selenium
so i hope you understood this from
selenium which module we have to import
import web driver we have seen this
in python sessions right so from
selenium import webdriver so we have
imported
so once you have imported we can access
all the classes method from the
webdriver model
right now what is the first step here we
have to open the web browser
how to open the web browser
so to open the web browser
we have to
call a class we have a class in
webdriver what is the class currently we
choose chrome browser okay so let us
automate all the test case for on chrome
browser and later on i'll show you how
to execute the whole test case on
firefox and ng browser first let us
start with the chrome
so i said one point beginning here so
what is that point
in the selenium webdriver is a module so
in this module there are multiple
classes are created already
so if you want to work with the chrome
browser we need to use this chrome class
or if you want to work with the firefox
then we have to access firefox class and
ng class and these classes there are
some predefined methods are there so by
using those methods we will interact
with the browser
so now
as a first step we are choose the chrome
browser right so for that what you have
to do is from the webdriver module
webdriver module we have to access
something called chrome class
chrome class okay
in the chrome class there is a
constructor is available so that
constructor
will take the browser driver as a
parameter so whenever you create
webdriver.chrome
you have to create a
object so driver is an object
now webdriver is a module from that
i accessing the class so for this class
i am creating the object so driver is a
object of the chrome class now
okay so once you create an object we
will able to access all the methods
which are available in the chrome class
right so we are going to learn what all
those methods are available slowly one
by one so just you need to understand
this statement what exactly we have done
here from the web driver module
we have
called the chrome class and with this we
have created an object this is basically
we created an object for the chrome
class
and one more thing is here the chrome
class contains one constructor so that
constructor is expect the location of
the chrome browser driver
so there the driver will come into
picture so we already kept all the
drivers whichever we downloaded earlier
right so chrome driver go to the chrome
driver folder copy this location
and then
here we have to directly copy that
location slash chromedriver.exe
along with the name of the file we have
to specify
okay this is the first statement
now what this statement will do is this
statement will automatically launch our
browser
will automatically launch our browser so
internally this chrome class constructor
will use this driver and will launch the
browser
so again
some people write one additional
statement here that is executable path
this is also right statement
executable underscore path
or this is optional actually the
executable path you don't need to
specify also you can directly specify
the argument
okay because this is the keyword
argument
in python we have learned two types of
arguments right
positional arguments and keyword
arguments right so if i just specify
executable path like this
underscore path this is becomes a
keyword argument
and if i don't specify this is a
position argument so anything is fine
okay so now executable underscore path
you have to specify the location if i
execute only this particular statement
which will automatically launch your
browser
so first step is done
and what is the next step we have to
launch your application url so how to do
that so to perform all other operations
we have certain methods which are
available inside the chrome class
so we should be able to access those
methods through driver object
because class methods we cannot directly
access if you want to access anything
from the class we have to create an
object so we already created an object
called driver
so through this driver we have to access
multiple types of methods to perform
these operations
now let us take another step so i want
to open this url on the browser which is
already opened by the statement so how
we can do that
so we have
another method called
driver dot
get okay driver
dot get is a method
so here we have to pass the url of
application so let's pass this
application
here
now this particular statement will
launch this url on the browser
fine so let's try to execute till here
and right click run fast test case and
see what will happen
yeah so now it is giving some error
so let us see sorry uh
this is a typing mistake guys okay just
a moment
just a second this is chromedriver.exe
yeah so now save it and then execute
once again
okay so now you can see it is
successfully launched my browser and
also opening my application url
okay it opens a browser and also open
the application url
now i'm just closing this now you can
see the output here somewhere
what it is saying here duplication
warning
so what is the deprecation warning
executable path has been duplicated
please pass in the service object
so actually this change is done in
cylinder four
okay so this is a new chain this method
is executable path is duplicated in
cylinder four but in celium three it
works perfectly fine you will not get
this duplicated warning
but in the selenium four
they have duplicated this executable
path
duplication in the sense in future
versions they will
remove that okay that will not be
available so that information basically
it is giving but still it will work okay
no problem at all still it will work but
because in selenium 4 this executable
underscore path is called deprecated so
that's the reason we got this warning
but program will successfully execute it
but how we can avoid this duplicated
warning i'll tell you so what is the
suggestion which is giving here please
pass the service object so we have to
create additional service object then we
have to specify the path so that is
another process which we have so i will
discuss that okay so for now just focus
only on celine 3 how we are doing in
cilium 3 and later on i will show you
how we can do in selenium 4 okay
so driver equal to webdriver.com and
executable path launch our application
so second step is also done
now the next step so we have to enter
the username
in the box right so let me just log out
so in this box we need to enter the
username so how to enter the username
here
so how our script will identify this
element so whatever is there on the web
page which is basically called as a web
element
so everything is there in webpage is
called as a web element so image is web
element username text box is a web
element button is a web element link is
a web element so all of them are called
as a web elements
so here there are two things are
involved one is our automation code
should identify this element that's the
first thing
second thing is we need to perform the
action
what is an action passing the value is
an action
so identify the element first and then
perform the action so two things we have
to do here right
so for that on what pieces we will
identify the element
so if i just look at this
inspect this or every page or every web
page will be designed by using html
language
so if you just look at the source code
of the webpage html code what they have
written to design this webpage we can
see the
certain number of attributes which are
available
for those elements
certain number of attributes which are
available in elements
let us say there are 10 persons standing
and each person is having different
antibodies so every person having
different color every person is having
different height every person having the
different names right we can identify
them by using different properties or
different attributes
similarly there are so many web elements
out there in the web page so every web
element we can identify uniquely by
using attributes or properties
but where we can see their attributes or
properties in html code we can see them
so for that you don't need to learn any
html so it is very simple to get i'll
show you so normally when you see the
page source view page source this is the
actual html code which is written for
the page
and it is very difficult to understand
there are lot of things are there
so instead of doing that we have a
simple option called inspect here
and this is available in every browser
so right click on inspect then it will
automatically show you html code here
this is html code
and when you put the cursor on each and
every tag here which is identifying
something on the web page
because when it saves one element or
when i see one element on the webpage
there should be some corresponding code
which is written on html
suppose i put the cursor on the image
see this
i'm placing my cursor on different tags
and corresponding elements are
highlighting on the web page
so for example i want to see the
attributes of this username text box
what you can do is simply take this
element so this arrow mark here click on
the arrow mark and whichever element you
want to see the properties just
highlight that element and click on it
okay i laid it and click on it
immediately
in the right side it is highlighted
particular html code in the
html
okay so the code is highlighted in the
html so this is the line which is
exactly written for this element
username element
now if i just look at this
and in html we'll try to understand
tomorrow i'll show you the locators
concept once you start discussing the
locators concept i will give you the
detail information so for now just
understand input is called as a tag name
name is one attribute or property we can
call property or attribute anything is
fine
ids and one attribute type is another
attribute so how many attributes we have
for this element there are three
attributes are there every attribute
contains certain name
every attribute can have one name here
name equal to txt username id equal to
tst sometimes they will be different
sometimes they may be same
and type equal to text so there are
multiple attributes are available here
so we can use one of the attribute to
identify this element
okay but name is there id is there so
both will supported by cylinder
webdriver
type is not supported
so name id is there so we can use either
one of them
so how to identify this element by using
name or id
so once you identified then we will
perform the action that's the secondary
thing
okay now let me just go and write one
statement here
listen this carefully these are most
important step enter username
so to find any element on the web page
we have certain methods are available
okay we have certain methods arrival
what are those methods
driver dot all the methods we have to
access only through driver object okay
driver dot
find element by id find element by name
these are the methods
so suppose i want to use a name so let
me take this method
so find underscore element underscore by
underscore name
and just we need to specify the value of
the name attribute so what is the value
of the name attribute here txt
username just specify that
now this particular statement will
identify that element
so find element by name this is a method
and pass the value of the name and this
will able to find the element
and suppose if you want to use id then
you can use dot find element by id there
is one more method called find element
by id also will be there
and but if i use name here you have to
pass the name attribute value so this
will identify this element
so once you identify the element what is
the next step we have to pass the value
into the input box for that what you
have to do
dot continue statement
dot dot
send keys send underscore keys is a
method send underscore keys so what is
the use of send underscore keys this
method whatever we provided here the
same text will be
provided into the text box whichever we
identified here
okay now this is a whole statement
we will go and identify the username
textbox and pass this value in it
fine similarly we should also identify
the password element then we pass the
password now go back
and this time
try to inspect the password and this is
also input element
so name is available ids are available
so this time i try to use id so
previously we used name right so this
time i will use id
so how to use it
again one more statement
driver dot
find element by
name name id this time i have to take id
and here specify the id takes the
password
dot
send the keys
and here
specify the value what is the value txt
password and that is we already
specified the value is what i'd mean
uh admin 1 2 3 is a password that we
need to pass
admin 1 2 3
this is how we need to interact with the
element
okay so in the next two sessions i will
detail discussion we have on this
allocators for now just understand this
okay driver dot so every method we are
able to access through the driver object
what is the driver driver is an object
of chrome class chrome class object here
we created so by using the driver object
itself we are able to do everything so
we launch our browser using get method
we find the element by using find
element by name we found the element
here by using find element by id and
send key is another method we action
method we use to pass that value
now we need to click on the button
login button so inspect this login
and now what are the attributes are
there here
name is there id is also there you can
use either name or you can use
btn login so anything is fine so let me
just use id now this time
so i'll write the statement driver dot
find element by id
and here i'm taking the id when you just
double click it will automatically
select
btn login specify
and which action method we have to use
here send keys not send case send keys
will pass the data but on the button we
don't need to pass any data just we need
to perform click action
right just we need to perform the click
action so what we do is we have to say
dot click
click dot click is a method
that's it so these three statements will
perform the operation pass the username
pass the user password and then click on
the login button
and then once you successfully logged in
then what is what what should we do now
we should verify the title of the
webpage is correct or not once you
successfully login
so we need to
check the target page title so this is
admin
admin 123
so now we need to check this title of
the page so normally where we will get
the title if i just right click on the
page
again inspect
and if i just go and see the header tag
you can see the title of the page
so title is available in the title tag
so this actual title so we need to
capture this title only through
automation code then we will compare the
title with our expected code
and again we will verify the
condition both are equal or not
so as soon as you successfully log in
how to capture the
title of the webpage
so how to capture the title of the
webpage so to capture the title of the
page current web page we have another
keyword called driver dot
title
it is not a method it is just a variable
so driver.title so this will return the
title of the webpage so i will store
that in a variable actual title
so this will automatically get the title
of the current page and store that in a
variable
and then what is our expected title
expected title
this is our expected title this is what
we are expecting store that in a
variable
so now we need to compare these two
validation is important
so this is the one so verify title of
the page is this one or not so these two
steps i'm doing now
so capture the actual title capture the
expertise expert title we have not
captured actually we are expecting so we
need to have some input data
now we need to compare these two how to
compare this by using if condition i say
if
if actual underscore title actual
underscore title
equal to
double equal to right comparison
operator so actual title actual
underscore title double equal to
expected title
then what we should do print
login test faster
login test passed
elsa
suppose both are not equal
then say print
login test
failed
and once you have done the validation
what is the final step we have to close
the browser how to close the browser
again we have a method called driver
object dot
close
so this will close my browser
so this is how we need to automate the
test case guys so this is how we need to
automate
so these are the actual steps so first
we need to import webdriver module from
selenium package
and then from the chrome class we have
to create an object called driver and
all the methods you can just look at
here we have accessed only through
driver object so here also driver.title
and once you perform all the actions so
finally i am closing my browser
okay now let us execute and we have
written all the test case in psyllium
three okay so all these methods are
available in cm3 but there are slight
changes are there in selenium four i
will tell you okay but in celium four
cm3 statements also works fine no issues
at all so currently we have installed
selenium four
okay but we have written all the
statements in three m3 standard
okay even executable path also supported
in cm3 but it will just throw some
warning other than that it cannot fail
our test okay
no problem so let me just run it
so now it is launched my browser open
this url of application
now enter username and password
successfully login
and once the validation is done my pages
got closed and finally got login test
got passed
so this is a expected output we got from
the program
now
till here
everything is fine so but we will see
some warnings here let us see what are
the warnings
the first warning is this one what is
saying we already seen this earlier
duplication warning executable path has
been duplicated so in the selenium 4
this is got duplicated that's the reason
this warning is coming here
but psyllium 3
no issues everything works fine
now there are two more warnings we have
seen here what are them
user warnings so warnings what is that
find element by star commands are
duplicated
so please use find underscore element
instead
so in cilium 3
we have these methods find element by
name direct methods are available in
cilium 3 we have direct methods are
available find element by id find
element by id or find element by xpath
defined element by css all methods are
already available
but in cnn4
what they are doing they are duplicated
this method instead they are suggesting
to use find underscore element method
find underscore element here we have to
specify the locator and everything
that's the secondary thing so what they
are suggesting is instead of using this
find element by
just use find elementor
so this is a new implementation is level
4 actually
because we have written the code in the
psyllium 3 standards
and we have installed selenium 4. that's
the reason these are the warnings we are
getting
okay
now i'll show you the same test case how
to write in selenium 4 what are the
changes we have to do how to get rid of
this warning so i i don't want to get
duplication warning like this
okay so in selenium 4 standard we will
just try to modify this code okay it's
very simple no change at all small
changes we need to do again i'll tell
you what are the changes we have to do
so let me put this code like this okay
this is a piece of code which we have
created in selenium three
okay so
i'll name it as selenium three
[Music]
let comment this
the commented entire line so now i copy
another copy here this is a selenium 4.
so i just want to show you what are the
changes but in the coming sessions we
always follow selenium 4 standards only
okay just for your understanding i
showed you this example this is also not
not this is also correct okay there's
nothing wrong in that
even though if you have celine 4 this
code will work just now we have seen
right it will work but it will throw
some exceptions like not an exceptions
it will show some warnings
but if you follow the psyllium 4
standards we will not get any warnings
okay
now let me just convert the same code
just do some slight modification
according to selenium four so we are in
series four now okay
so
this is the first warning we are getting
for this statement right web driver
executable path is duplicated that my
first warning we are getting
but in cylinder four
what it is suggesting is basically is
use service class some other class is
provided in series four
so for that what you have to do is
we have to
import a
service class from service package
so from selenium in the selenium package
we have another sub module sub package
called web driver web driver
inside this there is another package
called chrome
inside this there is another module
called service
okay from that
import
service class
import service class this service class
is available in which package
this is all one package
selim.webdriver.com.service so service
is a sub package of chrome chrome is
another sub package of webdriver
webdriver is sub package of silly so all
together this is one package in this we
have a service class first we need to
import the service class
and once we have done this
the next step is before specifying the
executable path
before specifying the executable but
just remove it from here before that
we need to create a service class object
so this is a class and i'm giving some
object called
serve underscore obj
so this is a service class object
okay service class object
and when you create a service class
object this service will take the
location of the driver so this location
we have to pass here
so this is a replacement of executable
path
okay so here
service object we have to create equal
to service and this service is the class
and inside the second constructor will
exp expect this path
and here executive path also optional
you can just remove it it will work as
usual okay so now service object we
created
now this service object we have to pass
in this location
that is a new change in
selenium 4 and here when you specify the
service object you can directly say one
keyword called service equal to
service equal to
so this is a new change in selenium four
in cylindry directly we can specify here
executable underscore path equal to
location
okay but in selenium 4
we have to specify the
service object class we have to create
object we have to create for service
class and here we have to specify the
location and this service object we have
to pass here and this is a how we can
uh
avoid the warning regarding executable
path now let us execute this code and
see
so same import webdriver we already
imported here okay so now if i just
execute we will not see that warning
this time executable path warning will
be removed
okay now you can just see
these are the two warnings are coming
from find elements but
executable warning executable uh
file executable path that warning is
gone so we haven't seen that warning
here
okay this is a one new change okay
and uh what is another uh
other warnings we are getting for find
element
right so these three statements we have
to slightly modify so let me just read
that
warnings what they are exactly giving so
it is launching my web page
and doing all the operations
yeah so now you can just look at these
two warnings what is saying
find underscore element by commands are
duplicated use find element instead so
now we have to use find element find
underscore element method in selenium 4
so let's try to use it so even that
method also will able to access only
through driver
so now
instead of writing this statement like
this
what i will do is i will write like this
observe this
driver dot
find element this is the method
driver dot find element and this method
will take two arguments one is a locator
other one is a value so here i want to
use name locator so for that we have to
use something called by dot
name by dot name is there
by dot name
comma
in the double quotations we have to
specify the value of the name is txt
username that we have to specify
dots and degrees is as usual dot
send keys of admin
so this is a cylinder 3 standard and
this is selenium 4
okay but this standard will work
in cm3 as well as in 4
but this works only selenium 4
and why it is giving bi is a error
because we have to import this by
also from a different package what is
that
psyllium.webdriver.com.buy.buy so this
by class is available in some package
that we need to just click on here which
will automatically import you no need to
import manually
so you can see from selenium web driver
common dot by it is imported by class
now we have used here so for this
statement this is a replacement so we
can just remove this
okay so when i use find element we have
to pass the this part is a locator what
kind of locator you want to use
locator in the sense for now just
understanding attribute which attribute
you want to use and what is the value of
that
and this will able to find the element
and perform the action
and same thing we have to do this also
so here i am using id right for that
what we will do
for id
so i can say driver
find element find underscore element
and by dot id these are uppercase
characters id name these are uppercase
characters comma second argument is a
value of the id that we need to pass
and send keys is a common thing send
keys
admin one two three
admin
and you can just remove the statement
done so same thing for
uh button also
driver dot
find element sorry
driver dot find underscore element
find underscore
element
and uh id we use right so by dot id
and the second parameter is a value of
the id that we have to pass
dot
send keys sorry not sending keys dot
click
dot click so you can just remove the
statement
so this is a another change in selenium
four so previously we have
uh these methods find element by name
find element by directly we can pass the
value
but in selenium four they have
duplicated these statements so the newly
introduced find underscore element
method
and find underscore element method we'll
take two arguments one is locator the
second parameter is the actual value
and rest of the things are exactly the
same
so now
instead of executable path we have
specified service
and instead of find element by id find
element by name instead of using these
methods we directly use find element
method along with the locator and value
so this time when you execute this code
you will not see any warnings in the
console window
now i have executed my code now you can
just look at you don't see any
warnings in the console window in the
terminal
yes now you can see
login test is got passed and all the
warnings have gone
so now this time we followed cylinder 4
standard exactly psyllium for whatever
the new things are introduced we have
used them so earlier these are our
psyllium iii this is also perfectly fine
but in the cylinder four these things
are duplicated
okay
so this is how we need to automate a
basic test case
so in the coming sessions we follow only
cylinder four standard only okay so not
celium three just for your understanding
as shown here suppose tomorrow if you
see some examples anywhere in the google
so by seeing these methods you will be
having some confusion so that's the
reason i shown you two different
approaches one cm3 and selenium four
both are correct but the latest future
versions we need to always focus so
cinema 4 standards we are going to
follow in the coming sessions
and now one more thing i want to show
you here
in the selenium 3
we are explicitly specifying the path
in executable underscore path
even in the cylinder 4 we are specifying
the location of the driver
right
but uh is there any way to launch my
browser without specifying the driver i
don't want to specify these locations
like this every time in every program
so i just want to avoid that just i
create a object of chrome class that's
it here i will create only object of
chrome class i don't want to create any
service object i don't want to pass any
location but still i want to execute my
code
so is it possible or not
yes it is possible so let me show you
how it is possible without specifying
the driver location but driver should be
there but we are not specifying the
driver location driver is required so we
should not avoid downloading the driver
driver should be there but we are not
specifying the location of the driver
but however script will identify the
driver that i'll show you so now again
go back to the selenium 3
okay
so here
what i will do is i'll just commenting
this statement
instead of doing that i say driver equal
to
webdriver.chrome
i'm not specifying any driver just i
specified only this
okay
now when you execute the script
now observe this what will happen i'm
not specified any driver location but
still it is launching my browser it is
launching my application url and
everything this goes well
nothing wrong in this right
but how it is possible
if you do the same thing you will run
into issues
so without specifying this executable
path also it is launching my chrome
browser from where it is getting the
driver path
so for that we need to do a simple
configuration okay i'll tell you that so
what is the configuration you have to do
this is you have to go to the python
installation location so where you have
installed python you have to go to that
location so by default a python is
installed
this location this is the default
location okay
the user's admin app data this is
actually hidden folders you cannot
directly see them you have to directly
copy the path
okay so this is a
python location where exactly my python
is installed
python3.3.9 go to this folder
and inside this you can see something
called scripts folder
now go to the scripts folder
i kept all my drivers here you can just
look at here chromedriver.exe geco
driver msh driver
so because i copied these three drivers
in this location
by default our pi charm will get the
locations of those drivers
so that's the reason we no need to
specify the path explicitly so even
though we are not specified this still
it will get the driver from that
location
so that is a concept here
so suppose i remove this driver now you
can just look at here chrome driver i am
deleting here
so it is not allowing to delete so what
you can do is i need to kill the process
let me just clean up
okay now i'm just deleting this driver
now observe what happens from this
location i am deleting this driver now
chrome driver is not available now go
back and run the script one more time
with the same
statement i am not specified any
location okay now execute this
and we'll see what happens it is
throwing an error
what is an error it is throwing
you can see
file not found error system cannot find
the file specified
where it is not able to find anywhere
the driver is required it is not fine
not finding the here you can see chrome
driver executable needs to be in the
path
so that's the reason it is cannot
so how we can overcome this problem so
we instead of specifying this location
you can just want to write only class
because every time i don't want to write
this location in every program so to
avoid that this is another way we have
simple
go to the location of python where you
have installed python and go to this
python folder go to the scripts folder
here you can keep all the drivers so
again i will copy the chrome driver here
so normally i put inside the drivers
right so go to the c
drivers
chrome driver and just copy from here
and paste over here so once you paste it
here then again go back and execute the
script which will get the driver from
that location and script will execute as
usual
so this time we will not get any issues
yeah it is getting some issue because it
is something different just a second
just a moment it is launching my browser
just a second hold on
so let me
[Music]
run this one more time it is executed
these are different warnings so let me
just execute one more time
so i already copied the chrome driver in
this location it is already there so
normally when you copy these divers so
sometimes you need to restart your pie
jump okay that is manually required
so let me just close and restart my
pyjama so first of all let me run one
more time if it is not working then i
will restart it okay
so right click run first test place
yeah now it is launched in my browser
open the application
yeah now it is taking the driver
perfectly fine
and it is closed and login test is not
passed
okay sometimes if it is not taken then
you can just restart your pie chart okay
so this is a option which we have
if you don't if you don't want to
specify the executable path still fine
but you need to copy all the drivers in
the script folder
so i will also show you that location
you can just and wherever you have
installed python so we need to go there
and keep the drivers in that location
okay so this is a python default
location if you keep the all the drivers
in this location you no need to specify
the path in your code same thing for
selenium 4 also
okay let me just comment this code
and don't specify both okay so either
one this one or this one
now even cylinder 4 also now let me just
enable the cylinder 4.
now here also we can simply avoid the
statement so instead of creating this
service object and everything
i just
comment this statement
and also this is commented
and then just write
only
driver equal to chrome
okay
driver equal to webdriver.chrome
webdriver.com
so i'm not specified any location here i
remove service object everything just i
specify driver.com so this will also
automatically get the driver from that
location
run as a fastest case
okay now we can see it is launching my
browser and doing the stuff
so this is how we can simply write the
test case in celium three and four
slight differences are there but once
you start practicing
you will be able to understand that
clear everyone
so this is a code from selenium four so
if you are confusing just follow one
okay for now i can just comment this
i can enable this and i'll put two
comments you can just enable this uh you
can just ignore this statement if you
copy the driver perfectly fine you can
enable this code it will work
in selenium four
so you can just
comment this one and follow these two
statements
these two statements must be there
so this is again same as usual same same
code
okay so this is how we need to automate
a basic task suppose tomorrow if you
want to run the same test case on
firefox browser or ng browser then what
you have to do
you no need to change the entire code
just you need to change only one
statement what is that instead of chrome
class you have to use web driver dot
firefox or webdriver.h
and executable path you have to specify
so edge executable path chrome driver
path similarly hd driver path firefox
driver path you have to specify this is
only one change you have to do
same thing here also so here same
service object how to create instead of
specifying the location of chrome driver
specify the location of edge driver and
here instead of chrome class use edge
class or firefox class
that's the only change you have to do
and rest of the code will be executed on
the particular browser as usual
okay so this is how we need to automate
the test case in selenium using python
okay so based on this i'll give you one
assignment today and the same kind of
test case and you guys can try this and
follow cylin four standard
okay so not celine three so we are going
to work with only cdm4 so this is
another test case i am just giving so
this is the application url
open this application
once you open this application you can
see some login screen the same steps
only application user and password got
chain now you can just look at here as
soon as you open this application by
default email and password there are
some default values are displayed
so before entering the username here
once you identify this element when you
pass the username what happens it will
apply like this
so this is incorrect this will append
with the existing value so before
entering the username first of all you
need to clear the text box
clear how to clear through automation
you have to use one more method called
clear
clear method you have to use that is
also there i'll show you so suppose let
me take this element
so before entering the admin i want to
clear this element what you will do
first identify the element dot there is
a method called clear
so first same element
first to clear it and then on the same
element then pass the value
okay so this is the technique you have
to use if i don't clear that field the
username will become false or username
become incorrect so you have to do that
even password also first we have to
clear it and then enter the password and
after that click on the login link so
once you inspect this login screen login
also
and what are the attributes are there
type is there class is there but you
don't see any id or name here
you don't know you it is not displaying
any idea or name here but how we can
locate this element
how to locate this element
so if i don't have any id or name we
will go with the xpath locator so that's
another option we have
so in the next two sessions i will
detail and discuss about locators
concept for now what we have to do is
how to get the xpath of the element
so just right click on this code
copy
and here there is an option called copy
xpath just copy this x path
and that will automatically generate one
x path like this this is x path
so in the next session i will give you
more information about xpath and
everything we will have two more
sessions on locators dedicated sessions
for only locators very important concept
so for now just follow this one because
we don't have name or id for this
element
but how to use this expert in our
automation code
so if you want to use this expert in
you have to do like this
so for example that is a button right
simply say driver dot
again find element the method is same
and instead of buy dot name or buy dot
id here we have to take x path
okay comma in the double quotations copy
the text path whatever you captured
like this
okay driver dot find element
by dot xpath is one parameter second
parameter is the whole x path and here
you can just say dot click
dot click
so this is how we need to write
additional statements especially for
assignment okay
i'll also give the clue here you can
just especially only for this particular
step and rest of the things you will
know again
because same steps you have given
only application username passwords they
have got changed and again once you
successfully login
find out the title of the page and then
check the title of the
expected title and actual title and
finally close the browser
so you can first try the first test case
whatever explained in the session
and then try this assignment
okay so rest of the concepts we will
continue in the tomorrow session
i am stopping here okay